hi I'm Erik Bosse and Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 4 showed that when it
comes to the secret of jon snow's
lineage gossip and Westeros spreads
faster than a dozen an office break room
and I get it coffee gets me Gosling -
this episode restored Game of Thrones to
the backstabby political intrigue of the
show's earlier seasons I got a whole
bunch of secret plane conspiracy
theories brewing up here and I'm gonna
dig into him in another in-depth scene
by scene analysis breaking down the
subtle details and hidden layers of
meaning that you might have overlooked
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
episode yet episode opens with the
corpse of Sir Jorah Mormont laid on a
funeral pyre for Daenerys this episode
depicts loss after loss for her as
members of her family either die before
our eyes or turn against her the episode
is titled the last of the Starks but
it's actually about being the last of
any family whether it's Stark Targaryen
or evidenced by the deaths of Jorah and
Lyanna house Mormont this funeral pyre
reminds us of the one for Danny's late
husband Aquaman who just peed on the
flames that gave her strength
this second pyre marks another shift in
Daenerys power a descent into madness as
she realizes that any family members
left to bury her and mourn her are
disappearing
Dany whispers something in jours ear the
closed captioning transcribed sit as
indistinct whispering which is an odd
couple words for her to say to him
seriously though if you listen closely
you can make out the words miss you I
think seems like the show kept it a
mystery to mirror the mystery of Joris
final words to Daenerys in episode three
and if you listen closely throughout
this funeral sequence the music might
sound familiar
composure Ramin Djawadi is using his
night King theme from episode three
[Music]
except instead of piano Djawadi returns
to strings because piano is an
instrument he uses only in rare
occasions like the near victory of a
supernatural ice demon the strings cover
connotes the night Kings lingering
scar-tissue the human loss that these
survivors must live with on the corpse
of Theon Greyjoy's Sansa tucks a stark
direwolf pin as a way of saluting Theon
as a member of House Stark we're calling
John for giving and renaming Theon as a
gradually and a stark last season you
don't need to choose you're a Greyjoy
and you're stopped a wider shot reveals
the scale of this death toll a vast grid
of pyres further behind this grid is a
mound wondering that this is the bones
and limbs of the zombie whites of the
army of the Dead that showed up left to
rot but these pyres are being burned as
a northern tradition to burn their dead
not necessarily at a White Walkers
superstition but to honor them and yeah
because no one's gonna dig graves for
thousands of people in that rock-hard
permafrost Jon's direwolf ghost is
revealed to have survived last episode
though he is bloodied up and he's
missing an ear while Daenerys is
Dothraki bloodrider kono didn't survive
the cavalry charge minuting hardly
thought of him at all did you Jon gives
this eulogy it is our duty and our honor
to keep them alive in memory for those
who come after us and those who come
after there he's calling back bran and
Sam's description of human memory the
night king wanted to erase their history
killing all of them in an even deeper
permanent way so by insisting on the
memory of the Fallen John is
immortalizing them John also quotes the
vows of the Nights Watch
they were the shields that God at the
realms of men dollarz Ed's death marked
the end of the Nights Watch but all of
these soldiers served as brothers of the
Nights Watch with the wall destroyed
Winterfell became their wall the line
upon which Winterfell
it at the feast and there's singles out
ginjury as son of Robert Baratheon or
former enemy but since all the Baratheon
czar dead that leaves the Lord of storms
end kind of a mystery so if he's Lord of
storms end now I don't know your grace
does anyone yeah it's funny how none of
us even know much about storm's end
either it's actually a fascinating place
known for powerful defensive walls with
magical spells woven in rumored to have
been aided in its construction by the
boy who would later grow up to be bran
the Builder and it's one of the few
major locations never to be shown on the
series by legitimizing ginjury not only
as a narrative a loyal ally she's also
created a potential threat to her claim
to the Iron Throne see her claim depends
on the argument that Robert taking the
throne was illegitimate that it
technically legally belongs to the
Targaryen but now if for some reason
Daenerys Cersei and Johnny and cancel
each other out
Robert Baratheon now has a legitimized
heir with injury who now has a direct
claim to the Iron Throne after them
the reactions here are just perfect
Jamie looks apprehensive to learn that
Cersei with whom he conceived three fake
Baratheon descendants missed a major
route in her deadly Dee weeding of
Roberts bastards sir Davos despite his
heroics during the siege of storms end
they get him kind of a natural successor
to the Lord of storms in Davos is the
first to toast injury possibly to avoid
any implication of fili and snubbed
because Davos is a cool guy he doesn't
like drama pandering all this the Hound
doesn't care it just keeps challenged
out on his chicken Davos and Tyrion
discussed Melisandre and the role the
red God played in their survival the
Lord of Light plays game from we fight
his war and win and then he saw who
knows what he wants
Davos reflects our crisis of faith like
why was John Snow resurrected just to
have the red God work in other
mysterious ways there may be more
mythological answers coming but Davos is
feeling of abandonment cast these
remaining hours in a state of despair in
Christian theology hell is the absence
of God the way that in physics cold
doesn't really exist as its own concept
it's really just the absence of heat so
the departure of the Lord of Light in
these characters lives implies that they
have been left behind in a Hell of their
own making
man defeat them
we still have us to contend with Tyrion
complements brands wheelchair recalling
the saddle that he designed for him in
season one brand responds that he's a
tree and he's tired of birds nesting on
him also that he got the design from an
interesting historical figure it's the
same as the one town Targaryen built for
his crippled nephew 120 years ago yeah
cool bran is referring to darren ii AKA
Darren the good who ruled about 120
years before the present day
Tyrion actually brought up daring the
good when presenting Joffrey with his
wedding gift
look the lives of four kings grand
maester Kate's history of the reigns of
daeron the young dragon baelor the
blessed aegon the unworthy and daeron
the good a book every King should read
this of course has a book that Joffrey
hacked to shreds but bran would never
meet a laid a tree relative like that
bran says he lives in the past and maybe
there's a deeper meaning to his
knowledge of history here because
Darren's crippled nephew probably would
have been the son of Darren's sister
named Daenerys whom our Daenerys was
named after that Daenerys was forced
into a marriage and fell in love with a
relative which I know and it's a common
thing in the Targaryen family but given
these parallels with our Danny could
this be foreshadowing that Dany could
give birth to a [ __ ]
Tyrion Jaime Brienne and Podrick play a
drinking game similar to never have I
ever where if they say something true
about you you have to drink Jamie says
Brienne is an only child something she
claims she already told him but he just
says he surmised a callback to their
introduction back in season two give any
brothers and sisters my baby King's
Landing much more get to know one
another then Jaime says that bran dance
with Renly Baratheon and then she glares
at Podrick before drinking that's
because in season five Brienne told
Podrick the story of how the boys at the
ball teased her but that Renly was kind
to her you don't see me and on the other
boys cuz they would later Brienne
guesses that Tyrion was married before
Sansa and Jaime orders him to drink
Tyrion scowls and his brother because
it's a nod to Taisha Tyrians first wife
who was actually a prostitute who Jaime
hired to pretend to love Tyrion Tywin
had the marriage annulled he made Tyrion
watches all of his guards had sex with
Tyesha it's a pretty dark story and
Tyrion must be pretty wasted
Londyn Jamie right now then Tyrion tells
Brienne that she's a virgin and Podrick
drinks now I could just be drinking out
of embarrassment for Brienne but someone
interpreted this as Podrick admitting
that he's a virgin which would fly in
the face of his legendary ways with
women based on his singing a few
episodes back some are saying his
mysterious moves might have just been to
sing to these women
but later when Sansa sits with the Hound
in the background Podrick cozies up with
the woman that the Hound just scared
away and he heads off with two ladies
nice sauce on the hound recall his
kindness toward her in King's Landing in
season one and the Hound refers to
Ramsay Bolton torturing her Sansa says
he got what he deserved
I gave it to him Oh hound by recalling
her feeding Ramsay to his own hounds
Sansa is in a way thinking the held for
being one of her many inspirations
during this party Daenerys overhears
tormund praising Jon what kind of post
sometimes in a dragon a madman or a K
notice that doorman says what kind of
person not what kind of man I think he
means it but the lion hits home with
Daenerys like John she's a dragon rider
but not the king tormund is describing
meaning that that must make her the
madman as Daenerys reflects on this
Paris comes into focus behind her why
what he's sensing that Daenerys doesn't
have the pull with these people that
John does unlike John she's isolated
without brothers or sisters to drink
with which is a shame because many of
you noticed she picked up a spare mocha
latte and everything yes someone on crew
probably left a coffee cup on the table
my guess is that it was used to refill
tormund slashing horn between takes and
that this was the only shot of Daenerys
from the sad pathetic lonely angle also
explaining this just made me say the
word sloshing horn so let's just move on
whereas Daenerys once a family arya
refuses one denying ginjuries proposal
I never have been that's not me
alright his words are a callback to what
she told her father Ned in season one
you will marry a high Lord and rule his
castle and your son's shall be nice and
princes and Lords No That's not me
Arya is also calling back to her moment
with my Mary a last season when her
direwolf turned away from the chance to
rejoin the stark pack all of this
signaling that arias time with her stark
pact at Winterfell might be done and
she's ready to go back on her own
individual journey Jaime anoints Brienne
in this hot hot sex scene begins with a
close-up of Brienne sword Oathkeeper the
sword that Jaime gave her to reflect the
mutual respect they built for each other
they take off each others clothes
reflecting the last time they saw each
other in the buff back in the baths in
season 3 the first moment at Jaime
Lannister showed his true vulnerability
later everyone reviews their map table
revealing the battles exact death toll
how good hey lookee closely the Dothraki
slides half of his pieces off the map as
well suggesting that despite what we saw
in the horizon not all the Dothraki died
apparently thousands of death rakhi
joined Jorah in that retreat from the
dumbest Leroy Jenkins charge ever which
is surprising Daenerys winces when Varys
places the iron fleet and golden company
pieces down at King's Landing she's
feeling the painful
after burn of her decision to help Jon
up north if only she just stayed south
she wouldn't be so outnumbered but then
Daenerys uses some real interesting
words but before I get to that this
video was sponsored by expressvpn a VPN
allows you to browse the internet with
privacy without things like ad companies
hackers by where any of those things
tracking your data or secretly filtering
your internet experience expressvpn
masks your IP address to make sure that
you aren't being monitored so that you
can have that peace of mind you can just
live life knowing no one's peeping at
you personally I use expressvpn because
when I'm like researching for these
breakdowns I don't want people
monitoring me when I google is it better
to bury a body or to burn it it's for
work well for my night job but that's
none of your business
expressvpn is a
bein on the market and the number one
VPN service rated by TechRadar and say
if you're in a different country you
might not be able to access everything
on Netflix or YouTube or other streaming
services thanks to express VPN you can
avoid those weird restrictions you can
just watch everything you want to watch
normally the way the Internet should be
wherever you are
expressvpn lets you securely stream or
download content from anywhere anytime
it's less than seven dollars a month
with a 30-day money-back guarantee take
back your internet privacy today and
find out how you can get three months
free by clicking on the link in the
description box expressvpn dot-com slash
new rock stars
that's expr ESS VPN comm / new rock
stars for three months free with a
one-year package visit expressvpn comm /
new rock stars to learn more take
Baccarin in at privacy today
okay back to Daenerys she says rip out
treated stem root and stem is an
interesting recurring phrase throughout
Game of Thrones arias spoke at as Walder
Frey taunting the phrase as she killed
them all that they shouldn't have left
one wolf alive at the red wedding you
should have written I'm the best
character actor ever and I missed on
that show and when Daenerys says that
here noticed that Varys winces to
because he also said it and reference to
the way that sorcerer castrated him when
he was a boy with a hooked blade he
sliced me root and stem so root and stem
refers to this idea of eradicating
someone's legacy their literal ability
to procreate and make descendants but
also their memory living on and taking
root in future generations it's a pretty
bombastic comment for Daenerys to say
because erasing the history of the enemy
was exactly the goal of the night King
John just spoke out against this kind of
historical revisionism in his eulogy and
as I mentioned before with Gendry this
episode also reminded us of Circe's root
and stem campaign to kill all of Roberts
bastards how that failed with ginjuries
survival and now ascent to lordship and
a threat to her Iron Throne
so for Daenerys famous is another
example of her descent into
Cersei style villainy and madness in
this episode Varys confirms that your
Greyjoy has reclaimed the Iron Islands
and there's a new Prince of Dorne the
last time we saw Doran the sand snakes
murdered Prince Doran Martell along with
his heir trystane but in the books Doran
actually had another son Quintin Martell
and he became a knight
Wolsey becomes up
so this was just rata their plan is to
split their forces a larger land force
down the Kings Road and then a smaller
Navy and the dragons from white Harbor
sailing down to King's Landing
the idea is to blockade the city from
land and from see gradually starving it
in a siege it's similar to the siege of
Yorktown that ended the American War of
Independence which featured the combined
Continental Army and French forces
blocking the British by land in the
French fleet blocking Chesapeake Bay by
sea as they bombarded the British forces
and starved them of resources but
there's actually a much bloodier much
more drawn-out and less victorious siege
that they might be pulling from for
King's Landing here I'll bring it up
later
in the godswood arias states the title
the episode we family before of us the
last of the Starks these words put John
on his heels because he's actually among
the last of two houses Stark and
Targaryen and he's probably thinking
that Daenerys needs his kinship more
than these Starks do earlier Daenerys
begged him not to tell his sisters that
he's actually Aegon Targaryen and now
brand tells him to teal choice as in
whether you want to tell them John or
have them hear it from a wooden pole
that was lucky not to be accidentally
used for funeral pirate fodder so by
having branch tell his sister's John in
a way stays true to Daenerys no one can
really control what this branch says
bronze
surprises Jaime and Tyrion showing up
with the Lannister crossbow given to him
by Qyburn was Circe's orders to
assassinate them the crossbow that
Tyrion used to kill Tywin Tyrion tries
to calm this sell swords power resides
where men believe shut your mouth Tyrion
is calling back Varys is famous riddle
in season 2 about the cell sword in the
middle of a king a priest and a rich man
like each trying to get the sell sword
to kill the other two the answer to the
riddle is that power isn't based on
anything real it's just a projection
power resides where men believe it
resides it's a trick a shadow on the
wall
Tyrion tries to cast a similar tricky
shadow here promising bran Highgarden
twice as valuable as Riverrun with bran
Burke hauling Tyrion's offered him back
in season 1 and if the day ever comes
when you attempted to sell me out
remember this whatever that price I'll
beat it I like living but Jamie says
icon will never belong to a cut-through
know who your ancestors the ones who
made your family rich fancy legend silk
bran is reminding us of the ancient
figure land the clever founder of House
Lannister who famously tricked the
castor leaves out of their valuable gold
mines of Castle
so bran is saying that tricks and
treachery are as good of whiz any to
establish a house in a dynasty Arya
catches up with a hound on their way out
of Winterfell asking headings King's
Landing some unfinished business
ah I hear those air horns yeah that
unfinished business sounds a lot like
cleganebowl to me remember earlier the
hound mentioned this business to Santa
as well there's only one thing that'll
make me happy that's my business the
last time the Hound mentioned many
active plans down south it was at the
end of last season to his brother gregor
clegane
not how it ends for you brother you know
who's coming for you yeah brother you
know what's coming for you brother
there's a quick shot of Daenerys with
ray gall with the camera pointed through
the holes of ray galls wings reminding
us that ragel was seriously wounded by
undead vissarion in the Battle of
Winterfell now he doesn't have the best
midair control Daenerys gets a glimpse
of that as ragel wobbles a bit upon
takeoff of course foreshadowing his
later death because he's probably not
good at dodging anything in the air
sunset goss's the truth about Jon to
Tyrion and this was no accident she's a
former student of Littlefinger someone
who taught her to fight every battle
everywhere in her mind and she knows how
this information is gonna cause tension
within Daenerys his ranks and Sansa
hopes that that chaos will be a ladder
for Jon Jon bids farewell to tormund and
his direwolf ghost they'll both return
north with the free folk tormund tells
John that he belongs up north to echoing
Sansa's warning about stark men going
south to King's Landing but by giving
away ghost Jon is symbolically giving up
his stark identity so that he could
better embrace his Targaryen identity
John leaves salmon Gilly is well
learning Gilly is pregnant
Jon says that he hopes it's a girl it
could be a deeper nod to Gilley's
history keeping her baby son young-sam
away from the White Walkers since
Craster promised his male babies as
tribute now I don't expect the night
king or the White Walkers to return but
assuming we haven't seen the last of
Tolman door goes
a lingering supernatural threat like
maybe the reincarnated knight King could
be a terrifying thing for them to face
at Castle black moving on to the
Targaryen fleet returning to Dragonstone
but surprised by your own Greyjoy and
iron fleet
each ship armed with one of KY burns
scorpion ballistas Ragle is another
devastating loss for the mother of
dragons it's a loss of john's dragon
named after John's father Rhaegar and
the loss further distances Dany from
John with John being the more kingly of
the Dragon Riders and Daenerys being the
madman of the Dragon Riders this episode
uses the same crosshairs point-of-view
framing that we saw from run during last
season's battle but now the Scorpion is
far more accurate and mass-produced you
may also notice that you're on
customized it to have the suction-cup
texture with arms curled inward and
vulcan his sigil of the Kraken these
ballistas decimate Daenerys his fleet
the boat explodes around Tyrion he gets
knocked out by a falling mast echoing
Tyrion getting knocked out and missing
the Battle of the green fork in season 1
in King's Landing Cersei prepares for
Daenerys to siege by bringing the people
of King's Landing into the walls of the
red keep
now of course Cersei isn't doing this to
protect them she's using them as human
shields to prevent Dany and Rogin from
torching the castle using defenseless
civilians as human shields as they move
real-world dictators have pulled when
under siege like in Libya Muammar
Gaddafi's men were accused of doing this
this siege sounds like it's going to end
very badly for the people of King's
Landing since Cersei seems so willing to
let them all die I mentioned Yorktown
before but this siege might look a lot
more like Leningrad in World War 2 with
Nazi Germany surrounding the Soviet city
Leningrad modern-day Saint Petersburg
starving its people for over four months
there are reports of cannibalism it was
one of the most drawn-out and deadliest
sieges in human history it was actually
believed that Stalin allowed this
destruction on his own people just
because he hated the Leningrad City
leaders so he was happy to sacrifice his
own people just to wear down the
invaders Cersei Lannister might end up
being a similar Stalin figure who could
come out victorious but at what cost
because she's just sacrificing her own
people over and over again but Cersei
like Stalin actually hates these people
all she wants is just a bit early cling
to power and prevent the other people
from winning
zero-sum game notice here that Circe now
wears Lannister red making her a
parallel to figure Daenerys who's also
wearing red this episode too bad Queens
who have had children ripped away from
them as the rains of castamere music
plays Cersei passes are captive myths
and a saying so much to the breaker of
changed it's tragic that Musante dies in
Chains just like she began the series as
a slave of a stupor but she does leave
us with a powerful message of freedom
that I'll get to in a bit back on
Dragonstone Denarius lands to attack
King's Landing Varys looks her in the
eye to warn her that this is a mistake
calling back his promise last season
look me in the eye as you have done
today and you'll tell me how I'm failing
me I swear it my queen and remembered
that scene ended with Daenerys promising
Varys this and I swear this if you
haven't betrayed me I'll burn you alive
so it's interesting that Varys recalls
this exchange and then goes on to
conspire behind inheres is back in an
echo a throne room but perhaps this is
varus's plan he does tell Tyrion but
will act in their interest no matter the
personal cost each of us has a choice to
make
remember last season Melisandre told
Varys that he would die in Westeros and
now he's cryptically talking about
choices
repeating brand's choice words to John
earlier when Varys was cut root and stem
by that sorcerer he heard a voice in the
fire perhaps Varys sees himself on a
spiritual quest a vessel of the Lord of
Light willing to sacrifice himself by
fire as a martyr to further underlined
Daenerys his descent into madness
turned her people against her and then
protect the realm from this madness
Varys might also be orchestrating
another assassination plot like the hit
he put on Daenerys in the past using his
network of little birds which still do
exist in King's Landing hybrid is now
operating the gang of Newsies but these
kids might be willing to turn on Khyber
in the way they turned on pycelle it's
also possible that Varys could be
coordinating with Sansa who didn't in
this episode describe herself as a
little bird who would have stayed in the
children when Jaime Lannister appears
hell-bent on a similar mission he leaves
Brienne reminding her that he pushed
bran out the window he strangled his
cousin Alton Lannister and he was
prepared to kill the Tully's of Riverrun
in season six notice how he is
confessing his dark secrets
just like Breanna was forced to confess
in the drinking game earlier but it's
all to paint himself as a villain
to make it easier for her to let him go
to Cersei she's hateful and so on one
hand part of Jaime is inextricably
devoted to his hateful twin sister
forcing him to see himself as hateful
words here actually call back that line
in season four but on the other stump
maybe the ultimate act of villanies
hinting that is killing Cersei since he
just learned about Circe's win over Dany
and he knows his hateful sister better
than anyone and he worries that these
two mad Queens will burn the realm to
ashes this could bring Jaime full circle
as a Kingslayer now the Queen Slayer and
fulfill that valen quar prophecy from
the books about Cersei dying at the
hands of her younger brother we actually
went more into this question in westeros
weekly go check out that episode that
brings us to the final sequence at the
walls of King's Landing which Qyburn has
mounted with dozens of additional
scorpions the gate opens and Qyburn
appears evoking that scene from Lord of
the Rings Return of the King the
extended footage with the mouth of
Sauron at the Black Gate my master Sal
Don the grave gives the welcome just as
the mouth of Sauron taunted those heroes
with Frodo's me through the mouth of
Cersei taunts these heroes but their
captive Masson day the two hands tried a
bargain I don't want to hear the screams
of children burn him alive no it is not
a pleasant
Qyburn is hinting that he has already
heard the sound of children's screaming
as they burned alive because he heard
this when he held Cersei blow up the
Sept of Baelor with wildfire member
Cersei smiled at the screams of burning
people which if you listen closely
probably included a few children
Tyrian sidesteps Qyburn breaking ankles
and addresses Searcy directly bringing
up her unborn child doesn't mean your
baby has to die earlier this episode
made a big point of Searcy telling Joran
that her baby was his
now tyrion hasn't seen Searcy since
before she and Euron slept together
which if you're honest paying attention
should alert him that the baby couldn't
be is perhaps this is a clever tactic by
Tyrion to try to destabilize mad queen
Circe's authority with some gossip about
royal lineages the same way Sansa used
royal lineage gossip to destabilize Mad
Queen Daenerys his authority but Cersei
responds by having a mountain behead
Masson day in doing so she actually
echos the brash decision of her son
Joffrey who cast aside good judgment in
favor of a demonstration of power to
execute Ned Stark
Cersei protested Joffrey's order but now
she embraces her late son's madness
Masson days final word is true chorus
the high Valyrian word for dragon fire
it's the word Daenerys uses to ordered
rogue on to burn stuff and the exact
word that Dany used to set Masson day
free and a stupor so by saying this year
Masada is returning to her moment of
freedom as she is freed from this world
but Masada is also leaving Daenerys with
a really dark message because of course
the Narus uses drew chorus the same way
that her father the Mad King Aerys ii
would scream burn them all in his dying
breaths when he ordered his masers to
burn down King's Landing with wildfire
jakara sand burn them all essentially
mean the same thing like her father
Daenerys has found herself at the end of
her rope losing family members by the
hour from death or betrayal in the only
thing that makes sense to her now is to
burn it all in season to Daenerys his
vision showed her walking among the
ruins of the red cape but perhaps what
we thought was snow was actually ash and
this charred heap of King's Landing
might be all that this Mad Queen ever
rules over comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at ei boss and subscribe the new
rock stars on Twitter and also follow
our new podcast feed Westeros weekly for
early access to all of our Game of
Thrones coverage thank you for joining
me and forget reading Danny's lips for
whatever she told Jorah I want to know
what pod
told those ladies to set up that'
Menasha pod